you are psychologically torturing these
injured people who were trying to do
their part on behalf of a team because
you told them that's what they had to do
so my point is that is that is a sick
system that would tell people this was
their obligation as a member of a team
and then when it didn't work out
pretends that they're not sick
right it's diabolical and you know one
of the phrases I keep using is it just
seems like the world has gone mad and
and it's I want to refer that you know
if
worldwide mad and coven all these
behaviors that we're talking about and I
agree with you I I attribute the madness
that is descended upon all this is from
unrelenting propaganda and censorship
we've been sickened by the
information that that we need in order
to to live and live correctly and and in
harmony right and and yet we're pro the
information is in Poison we started
talking like at the level of the
journals and all of this and you know
that you brought up another point which
is the you know it was so bad the
propaganda and censorship supporting
this vaccine campaign was so horrible
and Powerful that
you saw this phenomenon because you kind
of touched on it where
anyone close to the unvaccinated I would
call them vaccine adjacent
were attacked and the one example are
people who got vaccinated and tried to
speak up about their injuries they were
literally immediately lumped in with the
you know the the ire and attacks were
directed at them and you know for me one
of the most memorable and heartbreaking
examples I don't know you've heard of
this case but there was a a professional
mountain bike racer um Kyle I can't
remember his last name but
he filmed himself in his car one day
talking about how his career was over he
was really sick and he was crying
because
he had been trying to talk about his
injury not only for help but also I
guess to tell others and he couldn't
believe the amount of people attacking
him and the amount of anger and ferocity
directed at him for him just trying to
talk about his experience and you know
that's how bad that got
you know any you know people who got
vaccinated were being attacked
well it's
I have uh become somewhat Infamous for
the catchphrase it's worse than that
but it's worse than that because
on the one hand you've got this mountain
biker and I I don't remember his name
but I do remember the case
who speaks out about just a fact of his
life he was a mountain biker now what is
he right he doesn't know he's
understandably broken up about that and
what's more you know this has
implications for his longevity and you
know it's it's a tragic case and it's it
is an Exemplar of a pattern that is much
more widespread but the other thing you
probably saw
RAV Aurora's recent piece about a
um
a journalist I think an editor
at a publication and the publication was
decidedly uh
enthusiastic about vaccines and mandates
and the
uh the editor
had a severe
vaccine injury an immediate one right
and these things get much more difficult
for us to Grapple with when they're
delayed right a delayed cancer for
example
the room to pretend that it's not
Downstream or the room for there to be
statistical noise or whatever but
this was a case where somebody had a uh
an immediate and intense
uh adverse event
um that was cardiac in nature it was
myocarditis I believe and
anyway the point is that person has
apparently still not come forward and
the publication that they worked for
hasn't acknowledged
that it was championing these vaccines
and then right on their doorstep
had an event that ought to have caused
them to think hey wait a minute that
seems pretty unlikely if these events
are vanishingly rare that one of our own
would have had it maybe we should look
into how widespread they are so anyway
my point is
our impression in the public of how
common these events are is Downstream of
a campaign to punish and intimidate
people who've had these events so that
they will talk about them as little as
possible or not at all which leaves the
false impression that they were much
safer than they actually were yeah I
mean I also think Brett you know when
you bring up the example of that editor
in that outlet or whatever news source
that was
um
you know not talking about it that that
seems very governmental and Military
censor I mean it seems like everyone got
the memo in the media Thou shalt not
speak ill of these vaccines I mean with
very few exceptions uh most media
sources never even
brought up the possibility that these
vaccines weren't safe and and you know
the the most
the most absurd and dystopian are the
thousands and thousands of reports of
young people dropping dead
athletes
broadcasters on television comedians on
stage I mean all walks of life many
times caught on camera young healthy
people out doing like once you're
outside doing an activity by the way
that's a pretty good comment on your
underlying health okay like I mean sick
people are not doing what these people
do particularly athletes and so you have
these and then the ages you know I am an
expert in sudden cardiac death it has an
ICU specialist that was one of the the
patient populations I had to take care
of those that survived CPR and it's
it's it's so incredibly rare for young
people to drop dead
and you have Legions of newspaper
reports report after report after report
after report of no anteceding event and
the vaccine is never mentioned never
once mentioned as a possibility
and the consistency in
the consistency under which that is true
you know and I used to read those
reports I literally would skim them to
see if the journalist writing about this
tragic and Unexpected death of a young
for a high schooler you know whatever
the case is you know
I was just waiting to see if
they would just you know unclear cause
maybe you know could it be the vaccines
or there's no mention in any of those
articles that's the vaccine it's just a
normal rare occurrence
now uh
I'm glad you bring this up
uh I've done a lot of thinking about it
the problem here I believe is also
obviously Downstream of the same
propaganda campaign we've been talking
about yeah
the problem is these events are
extremely rare
naturally
the vigilance about finding these events
and pointing to them is now unusually
high
right so to the extent that this happens
very rarely and you generally don't hear
about it but now it broadcasts an
individual anomalous death broadcast to
a much wider audience one has to ask the
question
is what I'm seeing an artifact of
sampling a much larger population
now I don't believe it could be and you
as an ICU specialist
are in a much better position to say
that you believe the level of this is
unusual however here's where I think
this goes
we have to be cautious because there
will be deaths
that we hear about that contribute to
our sense that vaccines have created a
lot of interest in young people that
actually are just anomalies they may be
some other environment environmental
exposure to something novel but maybe
it's not the vaccine
but here's here's the the important
point
this isn't a tough question to study no
right this is what science does
and if we were really interested in the
question of well
is there an anomalous pattern of young
people dropping dead there is
if there's that pattern and it is
Downstream of the vaccines we can find
out if we want to and what we seem to be
doing is avoiding finding out that's
absolutely correct but let me speak to
that Brad because in in my mind
that question has been soundly answered
with data and interestingly or maybe
unsurprisingly it doesn't come out of
the medical sciences that data that data
is coming out of the life insurance
industry
and Ed douds work on this with his team
I mean when you hear these numbers I
mean and how that story broke and how
that data came out was really
interesting you know there was a
newspaper article I can't time it might
it's probably over a year ago where a
CEO of a life insurance company won
America was apparently talking to a
chamber of commerce like it was just a
meeting at a Chamber of Commerce and he
lets it slip that they saw I think it
was either 38 or 40 percent rise in
death claims in the age group from 18 to
64.
from 2020 to 2021 so in one year and he
said in that same meeting that in his
business a 10 rise in mortality in that
age group from one year to the next
would be a statistically a one in 200
year event that's how rare 10 percent is
and here he is
telling a group of folks that this
hundred billion dollar million dollar
company is so a 38 rise and the timing
of the rise
perfectly matches the vaccine roll out
um that you know the data showing how
many people have lost we've lost from
the workforce actually from Death is
truly alarming
and so it's like we already know I'm
Sorry Brad I mean for me those vaccines
are a humanitarian catastrophe they've
caused hundreds of thousands of deaths
and you're right though we we don't
no one's talking about it
well look I don't disagree with you
about what the most parsimonious
interpretation of the evidence that I've
seen is I think it's quite clear but the
point I'm trying to make is to the
extent there are many people out there
who still don't believe there is a
pattern there ought to be an obsession
with doing the most
deliberate and careful study possible to
discover the nature of that pattern
right we're still giving these shots to
people
I can't understand that we're still
giving these shots to young people right
that couldn't be a more medically
irresponsible thing to do if it tried
healthy young people
why would you give them a shot for a
disease that does not put them at
substantial risk
um so anyway I'm not doubting yeah I'm
not doubting the evidence from the
insurance industry what I'm doubting is
our ability
to look at the reports of sudden death
in people and to know the contribution
of vaccines versus the contribution of
the level of Interest yeah and I
appreciate that point I mean that you're
right anybody should be asking the
question
yep we should be asking a question and
like we ask lots of questions in science
we have ways of answering it and there's
a process in which to do it and it's not
being done we have entire institutions
full of people who trained to be able to
answer such questions and we are not
pointing them at this one nope which is
shocking
foreign
[Music]